- [Instructor] In this
video, we're going to talk
about analog versus digital.
Something that's analog can be any value
within a given range
while something digital
is represented by a number of
discreet or separate levels.
To distinguish these two ideas,
I like to think about clocks.
An analog clock has the
numbers in the hands
and it's analog because the motion
of those hands is continuous.
They can sweep across the circle
representing any of infinite
times on that clock.
For example, between 3:06 and 3:07,
the minute hand is actually
going to be at some point
between those marks on the clock
showing one of the
infinitely possible times
that the clock can represent.
Compare that to a digital clock.
A digital clock is only going
to show you 3:06 or 3:07.
It will never display any of
the many fractional seconds
between those two times.
Digital only takes on
certain discrete values
and it has a finite
number of those values.
So an analog wave or
signal will smoothly sweep
across the infinitely many
possible values it has
while a digital wave or signal
will only be at one of a
number of discrete values.
So the shape of the wave will
be more square or step like.
Let's check out an example
so this makes a little more sense.
I like music.
So we're gonna talk about sound.
Sound is an analog signal or wave.
So if we look at a graph
of sound, volume over time,
it's going to have a smooth
continuous analog wave form,
both the amplitude or the
volume, and the frequency,
what we hear as pitch
are changing continuously
between infinite possible values.
All right, and that's because sound waves,
the vibration of particles
propagating through the air
actually changes continuously.
The very first sound recording
and reproduction technology
imprinted that analog wave
directly onto a material.
For example, records imprint
that sound wave into vinyl
and cassettes imprint
the sound wave onto tape.
A major drawback of this technology
is after the sound to play back
exactly as it was recorded,
that wave form needs to
stay untouched, right?
So think about scratching vinyl
or smudging a cassette tape,
that's directly deforming the wave.
So you'll never be able
to reproduce the sound
exactly as it was recorded.
So, technology advanced and
sound waves became digitized.
Here's how.
All right, so recall
our analog sound wave.
We have a smooth analog wave
that's taking on any number
of infinitely possible
values within this range.
In order to digitize this wave,
we're going to ascribe
numbers to the amplitude
at different points, all right?
Watch this magic.
So we go over here and make a scale.
So we're breaking up the amplitudes
into discrete possibilities.
Then we can go through the
wave and at specific points
of the wave measure what is the amplitude
based on that scale.
So over here, we're at the
first point of the scale.
At this peak, we're at the
second point of our scale.
Then the first, the third,
the second, the fourth,
back down to the first.
Now that we have this way
broken up into levels, right?
We can ascribe the
numbers and we effectively
turn this analog wave
into a set of numbers,
one, two, one, three, two, four, one.
Our wave has been digitized.
Now that digitize wave can be played back
through a speaker to
recreate the analog wave.
As long as the sampling
happens at a quick enough rate,
humans can't tell the difference.
All right, so the digitization of waves
is all about ascribing specific numbers
to some of those mechanical
properties of the wave.
The important thing here
is that now that the wave
has been digitized, the
digitized sound wave
can be reliably stored, processed,
and communicated with computers.
So some information is
lost in translation,
but once the wave is digitized,
it's quality will never degrade, okay?
And that allows for a lot
more reliable technology
because the wave is
represented with numbers
instead of it being physically
imprinted on some material.
So humans prefer to store
information like sound digitally,
and there are ways to turn analog signals,
which can represent any of
infinite possible values
into digital information,
which is useful because
information is stored
only at a number of
discreet or separate levels.